she looks incredible John Travolta
praises his longtime Palin collaborator
Olivia newton-john amid her battle
against Stage four breast cancer and she
looks incredible she doesn't look any
different than years ago you know so
yeah I'm very proud of her and very
happy about Olivia she spoke with the
actor at the Los Angeles premiere of his
new thriller the fanatic it's a movie
about what happens when celebrity fans
go too far hey you can't just come to my
private residence looking for me well I
never want to see in this neighborhood
again John opened up to et about his
dramatic physical transformation I found
on the internet this guy that had that
haircut and rimless glasses and I
superimposed it on a photograph and I
sent it to Fred Durst and he fell in
love with the look and then we added the
wine shirt and the shorts and it just
came together kismet and though the film
deals with the scary side of Fame John's
got a special place in his heart for his
number one fan my number one fan in the
world is Sharon Travolta she changed her
name to my name
out of love 40 years ago and she on her
birthday she watches every movie 24/7
and that's her kind of gift to herself
and me on her birthday autograph don't
let him do this to me
[Applause]
[Music]